what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are on our way today to
go watch uh Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania but before that I got hit up
on social media a bunch about these two
King the Conqueror specific trailers and
I was like all right well this is our
last chance to watch it fresh because it
doesn't make sense to watch it after
we've already seen the movie so we're
gonna watch it right now with you guys
so please go ahead leave a like also
subscribe and click that notification
Bell to get notified when our review is
up for uh admin and the WASP quantumia
right here on this very Channel speaking
of which in case you didn't catch the
memo uh John campia Christian harloff
and I are teaming up for a live event at
Flappers comedy club in Burbank
California Sunday February 19th we're
gonna be doing like a huge talk about
Ant-Man and the wasp condominia and a
bunch of other things I mean not a last
good time get to meet a bunch of people
it's gonna be a great time plenty of uh
you can if you want to get a drink
already let's get to it guys
you come from above
like him oh
he will burn the world to find you I
wonder who that was
the Conqueror the Conqueror
in the MCU
we knew we wanted to go to places no
never been
I'm hitting Ant-Man against a major
villain felt perfect
a version of this character in the
series Loki yes very true
this is wild
at the chair it's very different Kang is
an infinite number of different personas
goddamn right
you need an actor to be able to pull
that off and that is Jonathan Majors
yeah he's very versatile rewrite
existence and shatter timelines
yes
banish me of time
there's some details you told me about
how time plays within our relationship
love
friendship Legacy Ant-Man versus King
this is it people are gonna lose their
mind yeah whoa
reality League Ant-Man
oh small world
after
[Music]
the Conqueror he will burn the world to
find him on February 17th if you want to
stop what's coming gotta hurry
I don't care who this guy is use that
shot for so many things Joy it's bad
because it is a shield
whoa nice ant armies Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania ready PG-13 February
17th get tickets now man I my mind was
just kind of spinning there with there's
so much little nuggets of information
that the line that really stood out to
me the most was taking revenge on those
who banished him because I'm like that
could mean a variety of things on like
because obviously he's trapped here in
the quantum realm and what it seems like
this is focused on because while we know
like there's going to be multiple King
variants perhaps uh maybe not in this
film but in the King Dynasty or as the
course of phase five ultimately
progresses that there will be more kings
that do show up but based off of the
marketing and everything that they're
saying about this specific King that he
is indeed the main villain he is indeed
the king that is the ultimate big bad
threat or new Thanos per se uh so
especially if he's the one who's been
like banished at the quantum realm and
I'm like trying to have my own theories
of what it could be I mean some one
implication of what that can mean is
it's like someone like Jenny van dying
perhaps is uh in contribution with
others there who helped trap him here
because I knew how dangerous it was to
keep him out it could be referring to
the Council of kings and like he's just
too bad we gotta we gotta make sure he's
he stays stuck here
um but yeah that was uh that was
exceptional I get why people wanted us
to to watch this one because this was
the first trailer out of all the
marketing for Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania we've heard all the hype
about King the Conqueror but this is you
know an Avengers Infinity War when you
know Mark Ruffalo um comes to the
sanctum Santorum and he's like Thanos is
coming that's what this did for me yeah
yeah totally yeah and I think that I I
mean I will be excited to see various
iterations of Kang but I feel like this
movie definitely would want to focus
directly in on this one because most
people saw Loki but I feel like the
movies probably reach a little bit
higher in terms of getting to everyone
and I feel like here yeah you would want
to set the stage and really let your new
big bad you know conquer it you know
like command that presence before
bringing in other variants and stuff but
I just love the other glimpses we got
him I loved the look like you can really
pick out some of the details on the
Wardrobe the costume and whatnot and
also just that further sense of who else
lives under the quantum like who else
lives in the quantum realm near
chronopolis who is affected by Kang's
imprisonment here because you know
they're stuck in here with him to borrow
that Watchman bit
um and yeah I mean part of me wonders
you know I mean he remains was
definitely involved with that so maybe
we will get some further TVA
involvements because like whoever he
remains set that up with I could see
being involved with trapping Kang here
uh or maybe even someone Fantastic Four
related given the lineage uh with
Richard's family and whatnot and maybe
that could be at least a way to hint at
and tease the Fantastic Four without
like fully bringing them in and
distracting everybody with that
um and part part of me kind of feels
like me maybe they will want to kind of
keep any outside Easter eggs or hints at
the future kind of at Bay because two
this is a big Stakes movie for Ant-Man
they want this I think to be the biggest
and most you know important Ant-Man
movie so I feel like the less they can
distract from that the better
perhaps yeah I think though that they
are really setting the stage here and I
think what Marvel's really wanting to
implement is guys everything that you
were feeling about Marvel phase four
Ant-Man quantumania is very much vital
and it you will see how this film is
setting up the Kang Dynasty and of
course Secret Wars which is supposed to
follow immediately after that and you
know glimpsing this trailer too it is
nice to get these teases because then
one thing that some people might not
register about
um King the Conqueror is he he himself
is not really a super powered he's like
super intelligent he's a scientist and
you know when you're seeing him use
powers here there are parts that were
making me kind of question a little bit
because we've seen in other trailers too
where it looked like he had like
telekinesis abilities yeah which I'm
like uh I mean he could be just
harnessing some energy it looks like
while he's been trapped here he has
found a wave with the like the beams
that he has to harness Quantum
technology in order to create a set of
Weaponry for himself which I think think
is really neat but I feel like this
movie is you know we I feel like we
often say this leading into movies for
Marvel and it's kept happening with
phase four of face this movie for phase
four this project for phase four is
really going to be the big thing that
sets up the future the Multiverse Song
and all that and then a lot of times it
didn't end up feeling that way by by the
end of it
I'm under the impression I'm gonna say
it one more time that this just seems
like especially with the fact it's
getting the conquerors the villain that
this is super duper important for the
trajectory of however phase five
ultimately unfolds and I'm excited for
it I think this trailer is great and
yeah Jonathan Majors is one versatile
actor so to see him uh be able to do
multiple versions of Kang I'm very much
excited for because if there is an actor
out there who can pull it off it is
Jonathan Majors you know like my
introduction to him was Lovecraft
country where he was like a super kind
of like he was a cool guy but it's
almost like a really nerdy guy yeah yeah
yeah he was a very sort of relatable
character yeah whereas even just from he
who remains to seeing what he's been
doing with King the Conqueror with this
the bits of footage of this Conquest
like Persona I feel like this is already
a very different interpretation and it
seems equally believable so yeah guys
I'm excited Ant-Man and the WASP quants
Mania there's gonna be plenty to talk
about once this film is actually out uh
can't wait let me know when you guys are
gonna go watch it hopefully I can see
some of the lab event leave a like
subscribe before we go let's dance with
the patreon
Brian
pay my dude I just want to say hello to
you and to wish you a happy and very
romantic February all right you know
we're here talking about the quantum
realm but if there's one thing that is
not tiny or minuscule or microscopic
it's our love for you and the love that
you have shown us and I want to take
that love to the next level in this
month you know we should meet up you
know maybe go to a nice candlelit
romantic dinner swap massages tell each
other's secrets and things giggle a lot
have a pillow fight something like that
you know maybe get uh into an
altercation about who gets to you know
be with Greg even though Greg's already
married and it's not really a point in
even arguing about it but still it's the
principle that matters and you seem like
a guy at principal Brian so uh we're
sending you the love and uh you know
hands off my man's but otherwise
keep on pledging and staying beautiful
and sexy and all that good stuff love
you buddy
[Music]